all right ta's costume just arrived
you're seeing this first I'm so excited
for you ready and
introducing
[Applause]
taigel what what song should I what
songs should I be
singing all right Tao Mel how you
feeling what what are we doing today
good going to see my life you going to
go see your wife yeah
okay so no we're not going to go see his
wife yes his wife is attending let me
explain the wife's story to you so today
in uh Vegas there's this thing called
Haunted Harvest and it takes place at a
nature preserve uh it's called Spring
Preserve out here and this the first
year we're going to it last year we
tried to go it was sold out so I guess
it's that popping I don't know what to
expect it is a Thursday um so we'll see
because like I said last year everything
sold out um now about the wife so there
is a neighbor in this neighborhood if
you haven't already heard this story but
taica is in love with her um and they're
actually good friends they're the same
age you go to different schools um but
yes they are neighbors same age I'm six
and she's five oh my mistake he's six
and she's five um but I'm we're just
really good friends with their parents
just because the kids love each other so
much that um the mom was like hey I just
got tickets to haunted Harvest uh when
are you guys going we were going
Saturday they're going Thursday I'm like
let me switch it around switched it
around so we're all going to hang out
tonight that's why he's excited to see
his wife he looks soing cute in this
thing there
for so we're just going to wait about
another 30 minutes then we're going to
head out um this thing starts at 5:00
ends at 7:00 perfect for kids um at
least the time is and it's perfect for
us and yeah let's see what it's all
about so I was looking for this in the
garage and I haven't had a chance to put
any of my Halloween decorations up so I
found it in a box with all the
decorations and I also found this
so this is from a separate costume and
this I don't think I ever wore it I
think it was gifted to
me I'm just going to wear this we're
just going to do
this and we'll have a good old time I'm
like a raving
Kitty I remember painting these this is
this is all mascara cuz they were like
white I think and
I colored them with pink and purple
mascara and it held pretty well look at
that looks like I bought him like this
doesn't it jokes on you I didn't jokes
on me no one
cares okay so we have made it inside we
don't know what we're looking at yet it
took us 30 minutes just to get our
tickets in so people are dressed
up looks cute but there's still nothing
yet so let's see what
happens okay so there seems to be more
life here a lot of families music not
too sure what is going on just yet but
look at that that how
fun leave it to Papa to have the first
shop be what cotton
candy
yum yum is this what you think Halloween
when you when you think Halloween do you
think cotton
candy yeah there he goes can I get a
cotton candy and a
lemonade so we're moving to who town and
that's where all the kids are going to
get their candy and do all the
trick-or-treating but look at all these
like scary we got toat look at that
hands down hands down hands down so
scary okay I literally started recording
when it wasn't even that scary but they
have like
spiders and
skeletons and more
skeletons and we got a stick you ate
this in like 5 minutes I didn't eat I
shared with everybody I'm literally
eating the crumbs so we can put the
stick all right add a lemonade Sugar
Rush
o
beware oh look at that beautiful
hwk oh my God wants to be a
friend you're supposed to fight crime
together he literally said no no no get
away that's when he say no no no get
away he he's Spider-Man you're
Spider-Man you're supposed to
be look how cute she
looks
okay we've been walking maybe like 10
minutes now I think we're getting to
boot town we crossed a couple food
trucks a little stops for like they got
the scary lights you know the scary
street lights from like all the scary
movies like Elm Street or whatever yeah
and then there's cords I'm just kidding
I'm not trying to knock it but they are
pretty it's far and I'm just like I
don't know what's going on but maybe
it's good maybe they're doing it so that
the kids could get tired or maybe it's
for people that like need to get their
steps in it's like a scary steps type of
event yeah if you want to hit your 10K
steps come here this is great hey don't
swing on the pools anymore
okay I wasn't swinging on I you saw big
spider in the bush we have made it to
Boot
Town get that
[Music]
candy say thank
you hi princess look at
this so
cool yeah we got the candy
here
oh my good let's get some
more oh my
[Applause]
goodness look at this oh no no no don't
punch it don't punch
it ready sit he's a spider witch the
spider witch
boy now this is scary no thank
you scary
[Applause]
e behind oh my God what's behind the
column oops sorry
sorry okay so I think that was pretty
much it you just walked through that
little town and I think that's where all
the candy is and it's super cute for
kids but it really did take a much
longer time to get in did to get all the
candy so be
[Applause]
advised okay so we're going to revisit
the cemetery now with the Sun a little
bit more set not completely set not
completely so I'm it's dusk but it does
look a little bit
cooler that oh man the camera is way too
good it's picking up light really good
so it looks brighter than it is but
trust me it looks way
better so we are back home now my
favorites and we got Mia what's up baby
girl and we
got Cooper and
ta chasing each
other well not taica we got
Spider-Man I think I think I got that
his costume one size too
perfect there's a lot of butt cheeks
showing
oh he's peeing
again he's supposed to pee on the Rocks
so I think just because his front paws
are on the Rocks he thinks the rest of
his paws are on the rocks or he just
doesn't give a about rules just
like his dad and
taica
whoa
cool he got
away
one day I'll have my furniture back here
I ordered it and it's not going to be
here until like I'm like why why is it
taking so long what's happening so we'll
get our we'll be able to hang out here
have a table all of that good stuff but
for now we're just going to use our
little camping
chairs look at how beautiful it looks
back here
we have a spillover spa and right now
it's the water's filled up to the top
top top so you can't really see the
rim I swear this backyard relaxes me so
much when these kids dve me crazy what
are you doing with that no don't do
that okay so this is all all the candy
taica got for
tonight not bad not good but I like that
this Nature Preserve or the Spring
Preserve is doing this cuz they are
raising a lot of money so that so that
they can keep up with all the
maintenance of the place I'm assuming
that's what this is all for so I'm happy
that the turnout was so successful cuz
when we left there was a huge line it
took us 45 minutes to get in I'm sure
it's going to take those people an hour
to get in just to see what I showed you
guys um but it's cool man Vegas comes
out and supports all of these events
it's so strong in the family community I
absolutely love seeing it even if it's
as small as it is um I've shown you guys
when I've attended some of their uh
Christmas parades Halloween parades out
here in Summerland and it literally
lasts like maybe 30 minutes and people
are camping out at least a an hour
before it even starts um so it's really
rad how much the community really does
support family events so for that reason
alone I'm not complaining and I
absolutely love it um but I wish it was
bigger and now Pap was so C he was
supposed to leave to California today
cuz he has to film J news tomorrow um
but he wanted to be with us so bad that
it's 7:30 now and he's packing so that
he can leave tonight that means he won't
get home until or to my mom's house in
La until
midnight what are you saying that you
wanted to spend time with us so you um
you
foro leaving to Kelly in the morning or
in the afternoon time I usually leave
like Zang why you guys to say like that
during a comfortable time you talking
smack oh no what do you mean talking
smack I'm never talking smack never what
are you talking about NE do you know who
you
are what you talking about anyway what
were you saying no I'm just I don't know
what you're saying that yet you didn't
leave oh no because um yeah I wanted to
spend Halloween with you and well it's
not Halloween well Halloween festivities
yes yeah I thought was PR Cy so I was
like you know what who needs sleep yeah
we just usually I like to leave at
around 3:00 so I get there at 700 and
then you know I like wind down do my
but I was like that's called
so I was like I don't want to be no
dad I want to spend time
with my family and my kids and my my my
wife and my DS who your DS huh who are
your DS huh so I'm like I'm going to be
Cy and one day you'll have enough time
to put all this away yeah one day
you'll have a wife to put it away for
you H you son of a is that you
going to say I was not going to say that
were you thinking it but one
day oh by the
way since you're here all three of these
mess shorts are new colors for gym
Essentials collection where's the third
one oh that one so it's black on tan
and then
Navy and then black on charcoal yep a
launch in this month so why I'm bringing
these specifically so that I can train
in them wear them show how fly they is
yep and these are dope you come up with
great colors like that green one you're
wearing one of my favorite colors you
like them yeah it's a great color you
have a good eye this is a stinky shirt
over here wow
it probably does stink but not really
you know what's pretty cutie what I've
been really comfy with your mom so now I
left a set of PJs over there and it's
already washed so I don't have to pack
it so over there I already have Cy PJs
that's comfy why don't you just leave
clothes over there oh cuz it's always
changing it's changing all the timeing I
know what I'm saying I know what you're
saying I know what you're saying you
know what I'm saying play I know what
you're saying what do you want hey
where'd you come from Little Bozo up
up good boy good boy good boy who's a
good boy are you a good boy are you a
good boy are you a good boy yeah you're
a good boy goopy you're a good boy
you're really good boy you're a good boy
goopy okay so we're winding down te just
had dinner he's taking a shower right
now and I should be in there with him
now but I'm going to just wrap this up
um putting these
guys to bed too and by to bed means
barricading
this this one I'm talking about you how
did you know this guy right here loves
to chew on everything let me see he's
covering the spot that he was chewing
on but look he's been eating my
carpet in addition to other things look
at this
how what the we walk you we
let you run outside you have a friend
and he still chews on everything look at
this he was chewing on the molding
outside and honestly it's just puppy
behavior sometimes he could be bored and
super under stimulated so that's why we
do try to get him on walks and working
and running and stuff um but I know it's
also a phase that I can't wait for him
to get out of but I just can't have him
doing that over here he's pooped on
the carpet before thank God I have like
a steamer that picked it up so you can't
even tell but I have to do this every
night and I know that they can easily
jump it but I try to make his life hard
cuz before we had him and it was just
Mia perfect she probably peed and pooed
a couple times as we were training her
she chewed like maybe on a shoe maybe
like one of 's little rubber shoe and
that probably lasted like maybe a couple
months and then after that she was
perfect then we introduced this
tornado and as Cy as he is
he's a I have to hide
everything like those shoes I have to
put those away that box I can leave it
there cuz if he chews on it I don't mind
but literally everything else I have to
get it off the counter like he is a
Menace dude so if you're
considering getting a puppy it's like
having a child cuz they go through the
same phases obviously they go through it
sooner just because their lifespan is a
lot shorter than ours so do go through
the potty training phase the teething
phase like all sorts of
phases but this phase
hey you're a good boy but you're little
you're a little
you know that and you're
not even that cute and you're not even
that cute oh my God he's so cute and I
love him so much but I want
to pull his hair out look at
this look at
this whatever it's just the carpet I
know but something to
consider anyway I'm going to let these
idiots finish their dinner then I'm
going to let them go run outside they
might go for a swim they're going to
wrestle with each other and then I'm
going to bring it back
inside close my door call it a night and
sleep with my little mans cuz my other
big mans is on his way to
California anyway thank you guys so much
can't wait to share more Halloween
festivities with you guys um we do still
have to decorate our house we're like
mid October and we haven't had a chance
to do it ta schedule has been so packed
like this guy is in so many different
activities attending so many different
parties it's just or us going to
California it's just been nuts it's been
a crazy month um so I'm really
looking forward to this weekend where we
get to decorate it even if we're
slightly late because I like to do it at
the end of
the month before the festivity festivity
start so like in mid to late September
um but hey better late than never right
so on that note can't wait to share that
thank you so much for watching see you
tomorrow